We are celebrating all things design and that includes.
Yes, cause I love design, it makes me happy.
And that includes the history
behind some of our favorite styles.
I mean, who could forget the geometrical Art Deco
of the 20s or the groovy colors and shags of the 70s?
You heard me #shag.
But no style has had more lasting power
than Mid-Century Modern.
A look so iconic it never goes out of fashion.
In fact, take a look at the history
of this endlessly chic trend in this design backgrounder.
(bright music)
Mid-Century Modern design began in
you guessed it, the middle of the 20th century.
The end of World War II created an economic boom
that allowed more Americans to buy homes.
Progress in physics, chemistry, and even science fiction
resulted in new materials like plywood, fiberglass, and foam
used to create innovative designs
with really vibrant colors.
People wanted to move away from the gloom of the war
and embrace both the naturalism
and experimentation in design.
The future is now!
As the American dream became more accessible,
architects and designers embraced a populist message,
"Design should be beautiful, functional,
efficient, and attainable."
(upbeat music)
Branching across generations, mid-century modern design
has been seen in our homes
as well as on our television screens.
From the Brady Bunch to The Jetsons
and to The Incredibles and Madmen,
we have an enduring image
of how our favorite characters live in this style.
The mid-century modern aesthetic
is characterized by clean lines, simplicity,
and bright colors.
Pop art and the space age,
both seen as symbols of a modern futuristic era
help define the look of furniture and architecture itself.
And no wonder that mid-century modern design
is still popular in the 21st century.
The timeless style never seems to lose traction
with many furniture designs more popular now
than they even were back then in the 50s and 60s.
Fitting seamlessly into our modern day mid-century design
was a prediction of our future
and is now a stylist conversation with our past.
(audience cheers)
I love that.
It's such an amazing and rich history
for something so beautiful and so timeless.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪